as far as we know aliens have yet to
visit earth but as for space simile
dangerous one player recently made
contact with an extraterrestrial race
I'm Matt and the truth is out there in
this GameSpot news update
Xbox user dpser discovered and recorded
the encounter while playing the game on
Xbox one daily and vessel introduced
itself after the players ship
malfunctioned and went offline daylian
looked as if it was charging up an
energy attack before it powered down and
flew away whatever its true purpose was
it was definitely a chilling
confrontation the thyroids are an alien
race that have appeared in the elite
series before but all that was known
about their role in elite dangerous is
that they would make an appearance
eventually it's been a little over two
years since the game was released and
the elite dangerous twitter account
seems to have confirmed this encounter
by calling it something strange we'll be
sure to keep you updated as more
information about the alien race is
confirmed but for more stories from the
world of video games stay tuned to game
spots